i stand here before you today only with
my body present while my mind and heart
are in ukraine
preparing for something that we didn't
want to see
what we expected might happen and indeed
the worst did happen with that invasion
uh by russia in ukraine but we were
ready
and we stand ready to do more we'd
rather we didn't have to have a crisis
for europe to step forward and make
these big moves but let us also
acknowledge that sometimes in times of
crisis we are our best europe 27 are
united and strong and determined and
honest with our citizens that we will
face difficult
times and we will face pain but that the
price we are prepared to pay reflects
the struggle which ukraine is facing
today and which we never know what we
might face tomorrow and his spirit is
invincible we are strong in our minds
and in our hearts and we are united
now is the time to open the doors for
ukraine's accession to the european
union
[Applause]
we have to stop this war because this
war is disgusting
[Music]